наж Путин о коне был из Моли из мыши
сделанный в тигра Ну я Пони Путин может
умереть Путина смеют люди из режима мы
добрые Мы не хотим вас утопить в крови
Потому что утопим если захотим цена
русской жизни она собственно ничего не
стоит как Кончится путинский режим
повашему на западе всё время обещают что
сейчас их будут подвешивать за ноги и
все другие места продолжение холодной
войны в 2 веке Это как порнография в не
только несколько движенийче этого бы
было хрув бы сказал вы хотели кабиста вы
его получили Ніна Хрущова Онука
радянського лідера Микити Хрущова
написала книгу про свого дідуся і ця
книга ймовірно вийде в Росії з
цензурними скороченнями програма в
тренді спілкувалася з Ніною хрущовою
Вільнюсі і вона розповіла нам про те як
саме її дід передавав Крим Україні чи
існує на її думку у Росії запит на новий
режим твердої руки і чому Путін був є і
буде в очах американців голівудським
лиходієм Ніно Хрущова Ласкаво просимо до
програми в тренді Доброго дня дуже дякую
одразу хотів би почати з відносно
недавнього епізоду з вашого
життя у день заколоду пригожина ви
поїхали до Кремля і дивилися як там
виставляють протитанкові загородження чи
концентруються
війська нал бы противотанковые сзанце во
Як ви оцінюєте цю подію і все що
відбувалося потім Це був удар по
путінському режиму чи
ні і так і ні я пішла
пішки я Слава Богу живу досить близько і
просто дивилася з віддалених околиць
Кремля на близькій околиці Кремля було
дуже цікаво Бо що ближче наближаєшся до
Кремля тим більше відчуваєш що
байдужість народу
зашка зашкавает все убеждали все с кем я
разгорива і з ким я розмовляла дорогою
що все закінчиться чудово і взагалі
пригожен нам не загроза Путін нас
захистить одна жінка сказала мені я кажу
Ну а там начебто вже є кадри як люди на
танк залазять а вона каже це Голівуд
кому це все цікаво Я кажу А ви що
думаєте вона каже незважаючи на
патріотичне виховання я не шанувальниця
Путіна так сказала Ця жінка бо він уже
занадто довго сидить так то все добре
але сидить довго малося на увазі в
Кремлі і вона каже мій хлопчик там бігав
хлопчик приблизно семирічного віку
ходитиме до школи все-таки незважаючи на
всю цю піонерію а так він буде дитячим
солдатом у пригожинській армії на цьому
мені здавалося теж грає Кремль тобто Як
би ви до нас не ставилися все одно ми
кращі ніж як кажуть
англійською краще за
альтернативу так головна фраза Джо
байдена не порівнюйте мене із Богом
порівняйте мене з альтернативою і у
Путіна порівняйте мене з альтернативою
навіть Мої колеги в Америці казали як
Путін дозволив дійти Я думаю що це
насправді було абсолютно навмисне було
зрозуміло що коли він зовсім підійде
Тобто ми добрі Ми не хочемо вас втопити
у крові тому що втопимо якщо захочемо
звісно дозволяємо страшні речі вбивства
в процесі цього всього але як ви знаєте
ціна російського життя власне і на боці
держави і не на боці держави нічого не
варта але коли він підійшов до Москви
далі Ультиматум чи так Чи все і в цьому
сенсі я це відразу теж говорила що
все-таки знаєте якщо ви цілитеся в
Короля Ви повинні його вбити якщо ви не
вбиваєте короля то король переміг він
переміг і це його посилило Я пам'ятаю Ми
це обговорювали з різними іноземними
колегами мовляв Ось він зараз він зараз
ослаб він загалом слабкий це не питання
що він сильний але в його слабкості
поскільки немає альтернативи він прибрав
усю альтернативу Неможливо уявити собі
як це буде інакше Коли тобі на заході
кажуть усю Росію треба перемогти
покажіть мені країну яка хоче бути
переможною Тобто це все йому допомагає а
далі як ви знаєте випадково у пригожена
в тілі опинилися раптом граната та
наркотики тут далі ми можемо говорити
або про дуже довгий шлях Путіна або про
дуже короткий але передбачати що завтра
це все від слабкості розвалиться це як
звичайна російська формула тобто якось
та й тримається тобто у тебе бандаж з
одного боку розламана стіна підпирає
іншу але начебто вежа тримається може
розвалитися а може ще 10 років
протриматися дуже часто тепер особливо
на заході а також в російських
опозиційних колах кажуть це станеться
тоді коли Путін програє віну в Україні
коли йому там буде завдано дуже значної
поразки дуже коротко Ви згодні з цим
знову ж таки і згодна і ні бо я не
уявляю як Путін може програти війну в
Україні я просто не уявляю цього як
територія на 11тичасових поясах може
програти Росія може програти Якщо її
окупують а як її можна окупувати навіть
якщо вони зазнають певних поразок це все
одно ніколи не буде поразка про яку ми
думаємо коли говоримо про поразку це не
німеч на 1945 року окупувати не можна А
якщо не можна окупувати значить не можна
перемогти в тому сенсі коли кажуть про
геостратегічну поразку навіть якщо
голову цього дракона відрізати хвіст все
одно залишиться і продовжуватиме лежати
і гнити Як закінчиться путінський режим
на вашу думку тому що останнім часом є
такі розмови або варіант близький до
вашої сімейної історії смерть Сталіна В
1953 але для цього Путін повинен померти
якось зійти зі сцени або це
1964 коли відбулося повалення вашого
діда які є варіанти на вашу думку знову
Вибачте І те і інше Я розумію що Путін
може померти так тоді буде якесь
з'ясування стосунків боротьба за владу а
1964 рік це можливо цілком можливо
по-перше в Росії Можливо все Ось ця вежа
яка тримається з одного боку на бандажі
з іншого боку зламана стіна і все одно
Вона стоїть але вона може впасти
будь-якої миті смерть Сталіна була
несподіваною хоча цього можна було
очікувати навіть 64 рік стався
несподівано хоча Хрущова як я тепер
дізналася в процесі написання книги про
нього що його попереджали щонайменше
п'ять разів за п'ять разів взагалі можна
було зрозуміти що це з тобою станеться
може звісно і чесно кажучи мене
здивувало що це не сталося на початку
тому що ми бачили що вся Як то кажуть
еліта була в шоці У них щелепи
повідвисали там кожен реагував у
матвієнка була істерика у наришкіна був
серцевий напад
тощо після початку повномасштабного
вторгнення так 24го було відчуття що ось
зараз і потім коли здали Херсон рік тому
Коли прийняли до складу РФ ці чотири
утворення чи як ми там їх називаємо усі
мовчали усі виконували накази але
водночас було видно що усі хочуть аби Це
скоріше
закінчилося Я думаю що проблема в тому
що поперше на заході весь час обіцяють
що їх підвішуватимуть за ноги та всі
інші місця Коли це все закінчиться тобто
вони обирають менше для себе
страждання потім знову ж таки коли всі
кажуть що вас треба знищити то цього не
хочеться Що робити Ми зараз бачимо що
Фрідман поїхав з Лондона у нього це не
вийшло збирається частіше приїжджати до
Москви і так
далік так да так да Треба до речі
сказати що і тоді в
1964 році усунення Хрущова замислювалося
за рік до того але Леонід Брежнев
страшенно боявся а раптом Хрущов
дізнається тоді він нас усіх уб'є а
Хрущов вже дізнався і все одно нікого не
вбив це така собі банка з павуками але
тоді була Комуністична банка з павуками
порібікою баню з паками взагалі ніщо Це
просто рай у якому і змія і Адам і Єва
живуть у цілковитому мирі і
любові а чим конкретно відрізняється
сьогоднішня банка з павуками на вашу
думку в чому її головна відмінність від
радянської на заході і Серед російських
критиків режиму часто лунає думка що
Путін повертає Росію до Радянського
Союзу розкажіть по цьому пункту
буквально дуже коротко у чому
відмінність радянської банки з павуками
від нинішньої банки з павуками по-перше
я не думаю що Путін повертається до
Радянського Союзу Вікторія нуланд любить
цю ідею вона радянським союзом займалася
Путін створює путінізм він створює свою
путінську
Росію тому що радянська влада - це
коротко а він себе бачить на теренах
історії від початку і до самого кінця і
це на мій погляд важливо розуміти тому
що це не тільки ось цей відрізок Хоча
він є ленінськими методами Ленін хотів
революцію Зараз ми перебудуємо світ і
Путін збудує нам новий тощо тобто
елементи є але елементи усіх
тоталітарних систем насправді не такі
вже й різні це знаєте якщо я можу так
сказати це може бути не дуже ввічливо
Але зрозуміло це як порнографія у ній є
тільки кілька рухів інакше не придумаєш
просто іншого немає І це схоже все
безумовно але банка з павуками мене весь
час запитують А що б Хрущов сказав Я
кажу
с ви хотіли кагбіста ви йго
отримали ви кажете що це какгбіська
банка з павуками а не путінська що це
означає що якщо Путін завтра вмирає то
залишаться ті самі кагбісти при владі і
нічого не зміниться можливо залишаться я
не знаю я не касандра не Ворожка але це
і путінська банка з павуками тому що
кгбіська банка з павуками скажімо
генерал КГБ як його звати Сергій Іванов
чи навіть патруш
а майор КГБ у цій банці з павуками це
зовсім інше причому майор КГБ невисокого
зросту який каже що він вищий ніж він є
насправді тобто він щоправда
підполковник але він все одно майор бо
це його справжній чин підполковника Йому
дали коли він ішов з цієї організації і
це така щебанка з павуками у якій павуки
маленькі але хочуть зробити вигляд що
вони дуже великі показати генералам на
кшталти Іванова патрушева і так далі що
він між іншим теж генерал ось ви в
Україну Не пішли а я ось зараз тут усім
покажу чергову кусь кіномать 2022 і в
цьому на мій погляд теж Велика різниця
наступний рік рік виборів дуже дивна
історія коли двоє людей дуже поважного
віку головні претенденти на
президентське крісло у
США як це може позначитися на
російсько-американських відносинах і на
тому що у найближчий рік робитиметься чи
не робитиметься щодо путінської Росії та
агресії проти
України Байден на сегодй момен онщем
баййден на сьогоднішній момент як ми
бачимо принаймні зараз наразі свій
потенціал щодо України вичерпав бо
бюджет ухвалили без допомоги Україні
зараз ідуть розмови про те чи це можливо
Чи неможливо і таке інше поки конгрес
республіканці чинять йому спротив тобто
наскільки Байден протягом року який йому
лишився зможе надалі виступати за
Україну і отримувати підтримку більшості
це питання тепер Він буде зайнятий тепер
усі зайняті Ізраїлем навіть Володимир
Зеленський президент України сказав що
це можливо буде проблема якщо увага
відвернеться далі розпочинаються
передвиборчі перегони Ми бачили Ми
знаємо американські передвиборчі гонки
Це просто якщо цирк це цирк то це просто
цирк у кубі у квадраті чому за
ти про трамце те що ви сказали а це
означає не просто РК у кубі а цирк
просто в стратосфері тобто загалом
звісно Україна сходить і напевно дедалі
більше сходитиме на задній
планетод п на другий план на другий план
далі якщо перемагає Трамп то цілком може
бути Далі він вінже обіцяв що він за 24
години це все розверне як він
розвертатиме Я не знаю але швидше за все
він скаже зеленському знаєш досить Давай
там Кримський міст переставай бомбити
Крим віддавай а там ми може ще про щось
домовимося але я не знаю припустімо
Путін усміхається широкою посмішкою
чичирського кота і навіть ще ширше це
все може бути і я до речі думаю що
Кремль до питання Скільки він протримає
на це і розраховує та розраховував коли
не вдалося за 5 хвилин захопити Україну
як ми пам'ятаємо коли вони збиралися вже
бути в Україні в Києві то далі вони
розраховували на нескінченно
декаденський захід нестабільну Америку
що ось зараз вона згниє через 5 секунд
це до речі теж дуже цікаво Бо Хрущов
обіцяв загнивання Америки раніше Сталін
обіцяв потім Брежнев вона все гниє але
все ніяк він на цей
і може так вийти що станеться так що
його сидіння на кремлівському троні вже
24 роки ще до 2036 року можливе сидіння
і воно пересидить усіх усіх же скільки
разів уже змінилися Президенти А він усе
сидить так що в цьому сенсі звісно в
України Зараз будуть важкі
часит труд время у кінцевому рахунку як
я вас зрозумів образ Росії
залишатиметься образом ворога
і Росії потрібні будуть 10 горбачових
щоб це виправити одна із жахливих речей
бо ця війна все одно колись закінчиться
а наступні покоління на мій погляд наші
діти будуть ще відпльовуватися і харкати
кров'ю за той жахливий образ у якому ми
росіяни постали в цій війні мы русские
предстали в этой
войне А вот ничего этого бы не было
цього не було б якби ваш дід не став би
ініціатором передачі Криму
україніпереда к Укра Мій дід і передача
- це загалом теж формула пропаганди бо
дід насправді нікому нічого не передавав
ініціював я так сказав це не було
політичним рішенням це було
адміністративне рішення оскільки
радянська влада все робила політично це
було зроблено політично але коли зараз
кажуть що це було протизаконно проти
якого закону
вони про це говорили Вони виступили вони
підписали у формулі того закону це було
законно від того що це попутінський
сьогодні незаконно це не має жодного
значення Я думаю що якби не Крим то
вигадали б щось іще Абхазію б зробилиб
сли я не ю для Путіна Як привід щось би
було але оскільки Україна з Росією це
завжди якісь певні тертя то це виявилося
зручно але знаєте історія не оперує
умовними способами тому ми вже маємо те
що маємо але в принципі це могло бути
статуя Володимира цього
величезного який біля Кремля стоїть ні
який стоїть не біля Кремля який стоїть у
Києві вони могли через неї теж
влаштувати Бучу це наш Володимир
віддайте українці скажуть Ні це не має
значення приводи приводи
Ніно Хрущова Дякую вам
дякую
foreign